today we are going to talk about this
[Music]
it is without doubt the most beautiful
aircraft ever to evolve from the mind of
man
the concord retired in 2003 ever since
then
we've been stuck traveling at regular
old speeds but
there is a company in colorado called
boom
they've raised more than 150 million
dollars to build
the first privately funded commercial
supersonic plane
the company was started by a man named
blake shull
he came from the internet and software
world but decided he was going to be the
guy who would make
this machine possible and and so they've
been at it for a few years
overture is the goal and before that
they are building a plane that's about a
third the size of this thing which is
called xb1
and boom is unveiling it for the first
time and we get the first look at it so
let's head to colorado
and hear from blake about boom's
progress
and with that off we go to colorado
[Music]
so i've been following you guys since
what since like 2015 2016 and it was
early 2016. yeah
give me give me the whole thesis behind
boom and what
you guys are trying to do it's been uh
really half a century since we've had a
speed up in air travel
we went from props to jets in the late
1950s and in the
1960s and 1970s we made the leap to
supersonic with concord
but we never made high-speed travel
mainstream and in fact when concours
shut down about 20 years ago
there was really no plan to pick up
where it left off and so that's what
we're doing at boom
we're building a high-speed travel that
can be available to more people than
ever before
so i think new york to london and three
and a half hours instead of six and a
half
think the west coast to uh tokyo in as
little as four and a half hours
think of overture which is our airliner
as uh chopping off the front cabin
of a boeing or airbus wide body and
making it go really fast so it's got
between 65 and 85 seats
and we'll get you there and we'll have
to wheels down and about half the time
it takes today
if you fly xb1 next year this that would
be the first
private supersonic plane is is that
right
that's that's right when we fly xb1 next
year it'll be the first independently
developed supersonic
jet ever okay tell me just a little bit
about your background and
in retrospect do you think that's been a
service to what you guys are trying to
do
i went to school for computer science i
started my career at amazon
doing automation of online marketing as
a software engineer and then as a leader
uh but i've loved airplanes since i was
a kid you fly right
i've been flying for fun since college
you know i'm one of those people that
you left me behind the controls of an
airplane and
you got to rush them out of my hands
because it's so it's so much fun
and it's such a it's just a wonderfully
human thing to do
and technical and physical at the same
time
but i've been watching the supersonic
space since i was in my mid-20s and i
sort of
gave myself a life goal of going mach 2
and
one day i wanted to have my passion for
aerospace uh
intersect with what i was actually
working on and had no idea when that
would happen or how it would happen
but i feel i feel very lucky to be able
to do boom
why has it been since 2003 that
um nobody tried to to do this again
we're now at the intersection of what is
technologically possible
and what there is a sufficient market
demand for so since concord retired at
03
there's been a two and a half fold
increase in international travel
and that creates a lot more markets for
supersonic
at the same time we've had all kinds of
new technology that didn't exist in
concord's day we've gone from aluminum
to carbon fiber composites
we've gone from loud and efficient
environmentally unfriendly
turbo jet engines to turbo fan engines
that are much quieter
much more fuel efficient and when you
put together all the new technology
aerodynamics materials propulsion
you can now build an aircraft that's
significantly more efficient than
concord
which means it can be available to tens
of millions of people it fares kind of
like what you pay in business class
today
so you guys are doing this in this super
methodical way you're unveiling
right now this xb1 which is your your
first
plane and tell me about it it's
basically a third of the size
of where you're hoping to go with
overture which will be your first
commercial plane so xb1 is our
think of it as our like baby prototype
for overture we call it baby boom for
fun
and it uh it'll go supersonic uh it'll
be history's first independently
developed supersonic jet
and you know for those of you who are
familiar with the early days of spacex
it's in many ways analogous to the
falcon one
rather than going and building overture
uh we decided it was prudent to take all
of our best ideas for that airplane
and then go subscale and do design build
fly
learn on a representative aircraft that
is
as human rated that actually carries
carries a living pilot
so we'll be flying xb1 and setting speed
records
in 2021 so next year and then
as xb1 goes supersonic around the end of
next year we're going to pass
kind of past the torch from xb1 to
overture and
uh and so all the things we've learned
in flight test of xb1
uh will inform the final design of
overture we're going to press enter on
that around the end of next year
and then start signing up the rest of
our supplier team for overture
uh do the detailed design and uh in 2025
so about five years from now
we will be with overture where we are
with xb1 today where we're rolling out
the first assembled airplane and then
we'll be in flight test
uh starting in 2026 with overture so six
years from now you'll look up and you'll
see an overture
aircraft you know in the in the skies
setting speed records
uh and so we'll be carrying our first
passengers by the end of the decade
cool well i think uh i think we can we
could actually sort of like have a peek
down on the
factory floor right with xb1 kind of
coming together
yeah let's go take a look at it here we
are overlooking uh
xv1 and its assembly hanger so this is a
67 foot long aircraft uh so about one
third of the scale of overture should be
a little bit more than 200 feet long and
uh over here we've got about a 21 foot
41 foot wingspan
so uh this hanger that we're in here is
perfect for xb1
but over sure what we can fit in the
building so we're gonna we're gonna move
here in a couple years as we start
building the first
overture so the uh the last few
components are going on
and then we're going to lower the
aircraft down onto a field
and then we'll be ready to unveil the
aircraft for rolex
how many how many people do you guys
have working on the plane right now
we've got about 140 people in the
company and you know of which about a
hundred are working on xb1
uh either because they're putting it
together or finishing the design the
engineering
you can see here we've got the the main
landing gear uh that's designed to take
two hundred thousand pounds of load
okay we can provide even a relatively
rough landing
and uh up above it this is the input so
actually one
uh overture it's got three engines in it
we've got one
on each side underneath the wing and
then we've got a third one in the tail
with an intake that's mounted uh dorsal
in the back of the airplane
so we've uh we built this deck so the
airplane could be accessible
for installing systems and we call it
the party desk
building an airplane is like building an
iceberg from the bottom up
pilot sits here but you can get a sense
that uh yeah the visibility over this
nose isn't gonna be great and that's why
we've got the
the camera system that allows the pilot
this kind of a virtual window
it goes through the nose of the aircraft
they can see the runway better than they
could on a typical
subsonic airplane you can see that we've
got the
the nose tone is on now and we've got
that that silver thing
uh sticking out is the flight test boom
so that's uh that's a piece of equipment
that uh
measures uh measures airflow air speed
air pressure
uh temperature well outside of the
interference or the airplane itself you
kind of reach forward
you get a clean measurement and then we
use that to calibrate the sensors that
are elsewhere
there are many many many sensors
throughout this and then
the whole airplane has a real-time data
link uh
down to the ground the 10 megabit length
and so we've got real-time video feed
plus all of their sensors fed real-time
off the aircraft down to the control
room
uh so we've got uh carbon fiber
composite wings
and uh you know you'll notice that the
wings are relatively small compared to
typical airline wings so that's
one of the artifacts of a high mock
design
is you have relatively less wingspan
and that but you've got so much airflow
over the wings you can still get all the
lift you need
and then the trick to making it uh also
work at low speed
if you come in at a very nose-high
attitude called a high angle of attack
and at that point the whole aircraft is
in something called vortex lift
where basically you get a vortex
generated off the nose you get a vortex
generated
off the uh leading edge of the wing and
a vortex is basically i think of it's
like a little bit of air that's swirling
and so it's faster than typical air
around it and you'll remember from you
know bernoulli's principle that fast
removing air has a pressure drop
and so that vortex you have sitting
above the wind generates a low pressure
region
or also the high pressure below the wing
and that's how that's how the airplane
fly
uh well it's amazing man and tate you
know thank you so much
for your your time today and and uh
and it's exciting to see you know how
far you guys have come
over these last few years well thank you
ashley you've seen it from the very
early days
and it certainly has come away
you